I'd like to keep this reasonably
informal
no it's not going to be a deep technical
lecture but I hope I can stimulate some
people to actually think about a set of
problems which I think are getting more
more critical let me start a little bit
with background no we've we've had a
remarkable stint over the last what 20
some ideas 30 years with the growth of
the internet as some of the younger ones
may not completely realize the internet
was an experiment this is an experiment
in the new form communications initially
Paul Baran proposed many years ago that
packet switching a whole host of reasons
was better way of doing things than the
circuit switching essentially the normal
communication had the and basically
dopper decided to perform an experiment
in building an experimental packet
network with experimental machines
connected to it notice it was an
experiment it was not a production
operation was not intended to be a
production operation in spite of
revisionist history was not designed to
survive in thermonuclear war well
hopefully it survived the pile of young
students who were working on it it was
small good people is a set of friends
though we all knew each other now I my
students like pastel amok Petrus and
others were deeply involved in trying to
get this body thing running in that
environment the last thing the people
worried about where issues such as
security and labelled robustness to a
degree but security because after all we
were friends now who is going to do
anything bad and so as normal in systems
with those aims people started designing
protocols and eventually software where
security was
not designed into it and most of us I
think fair to say almost all of us did
not expect anything to particularly grow
out of this system in fact the airway
open net had severe limitations that
basically precluded large-scale
deployment of it so a an experiment was
conducted much to our astonishment I
think everybody's astonishment suddenly
a group and grew for a number of reasons
and you can depending on whose history
you like you can draw different reasons
the history I like basically is that
about the time that the APPA netam and
tcp was being which was a slight
elaboration of the original internet
protocol advice came along called the pc
and the pc was suddenly something that
could boy easily outside of computing
centers into homes and basically a set
of kids up in boston move the basically
the protocols over to the pc and gave us
the ability to do male technology remote
access a bunch of things and they worked
on desktops which suddenly made
something that was of interest other
than computing centers to operate and so
it grew and grew fast the there were a
lot of motivations to its growth do you
mind if I sit by the way otherwise I'll
wander around and give somebody a
nervous breakdown tried to follow me the
probably the the key steps actually and
I'll repeat I'll say this for historical
purposes and were that in about what mid
80s around that time the deployment of
technology around universities are set
with the despot nikkor
the sense created endless computer
science departments all over the country
quite often with one systems person one
of these one of those you don't do
research with one of and so there was
motivation on the part of the numbers
when Weber myself Peter Denning a couple
of us to deploy the technology that was
at that point available only to a
handful of universities and a handful of
industrial people to allow computer
science departments talk to each other
and that was the cs net activity i won't
go further into that except it was a
remarkable success much to our
astonishment how successful it was
within two years or so we had
essentially every computer science
department in the country was connected
together at least by electronic mail
often by x.25 connections sometimes by
internet connections right to top it all
off we did another thing more accidental
anything else computer science graduates
were in high demand in those days and
every industrial lab was faced with a
problem when students came up
potentially for jobs that won the
question so we're asked is do you have
access to CS net and so what happened is
we allowed industrial research labs to
join in at outrageous membership fees
which helped fund it and I'm terminating
fast this historical discussion but it
is relevant well what that happened is
that other departments of the University
asked can we join this thing and
computer science departments became
computing centers which was not a
particular low in life so the NSF
proceeded to fund the development of
NSFNET national research and education
network a set of regional networks which
connected those together many of those
commercialized and
we learn in the cloud of smaug Oh smoke
okay why do I go through this history
because the same basic philosophy the
same basic architecture of software
would still be used protocols which
would not particularly robust relative
to security in fact maybe the opposite
end software systems that were I think
to be mildly were insecure operating
quite often on hardware which was
equally insecure one of the lessons I
think we've learned in the past time and
time again is that it's very hot retro
actively engineer security into those
systems that's been true since day one
and the in the computer field if you
don't do it on I have to start you ain't
going to do it easily and we've seen
endless iterations of catastrophe after
catastrophe ah Wow argue that I believe
it's possible okay patience you know I
always try to actually make it flow but
sometimes we can feel free to derail me
I'm I'm good at that and the other
problem and this is a more recent
problem is that speeds increased in the
in the network the ability tend to
connect computers oven and maybe
supercomputers to the network has been
limited by the architecture of the
network of the processors the
architecture of the software so you have
a combination of increased demands and
systems which are not particularly
suited to sync those damp bandwidth and
that's going to become more common in
the future so we are sort of them I like
to characterize this is we've built a
system which is sitting on several
pieces of ice right and no matter how
you step on it you get slid and things
crash
and you see this constantly the question
is how long can we allow that to happen
okay now you could argue well issues you
know just said it's it's difficult
problem if you look back in history
though I think you'll find a number of
examples of systems which have made
valiant attempts at solving some of
these problems you know I could iterate
some of them some inventors are in the
room there have been a number of
capability based architecture in the old
days that actually gave rather decent
protection within the mainframe within a
particular computer multics certainly
provided a remarkably secure environment
within a given machine there have been a
couple of experiments and if there's
anybody here from Intel allow me excuse
me for calling this an experiment and if
things like the Intel for 32 which no I
always felt was noble experiment it
taught us off what I had five of them
other schools had five of them just the
side thing I was asked by the board of
Intel to evaluate it as well how good
was it for marketplace and I said you'll
give away every heavy university in the
country and probably sell none of them
because it was an experiment and the
experiment did provide a an environment
which had inherently a set of ideas that
were quite a quite good relative to the
security model I'm good I'm going to go
down the Intel path for a moment because
it's the one I know best but there are
other examples of this i'm not claiming
they're the only ones a later version
which sometimes called gemini which was
a rehash of the 32 architecture which
would basically capability-based
architecture with more modern technology
and the 432 was programmed in 80 if I
remember correctly which was put
amusing I'm not native phim particularly
the Gemini machine was designed to do
high-availability sensitive applications
in particular it was a joint project
between siemens and Intel designed to
create a telephone environment which
turned out siemens didn't like but of
his did I could tell a long story about
why that did not become commercially
feasible but let's do it outside the
recordings yes sir which actually did
have huge success in the embedded world
and the commercial products of the small
farm system where images that are they
fine diin yeah I was about to come but
it's Jan I the original Gemma I was not
very successful for not technical
reasons ok the next step where I was the
Palladium experiment that will Guanche
architecture which addressed several
issues one is the security model which
was rather successful over the other one
was to tighten the base architecture of
the 432 I'm sorry of the 386 family of
processors which was wasn't still is
rather leaky sieve it did a very good
job of tithing that we won't get into
why that didn't happen trying to get
into a Microsoft to work together was a
noble experiment I'll leave it at that I
I still have the whips on back my thing
and the saucy from community
telecommuting why not commit the shuttle
commuting between in Portland and
Redmond the so we're faced faced now
with their whole bunch of experiments at
cobham experiments until now has the sgx
and other things which embed some of
these ideas in there and there are other
manufacturers I'm just you know I'm very
familiar with Intel's thing and so the
question is what happened why haven't we
been able to do anything with that the I
would argue that the that part of the
problem is we succeeded we succeeded
dramatically in producing a huge
environment of people that are using the
internet and so basically the problem is
that almost anything you do faces the
existing environment where we have
hundreds of millions of computers some
of them still running windows 0 some of
them running hard Wiz it should never
run connected up by god knows what and
to try to do anything other than patch
and Phil just perennial perpetuates the
problem and you can see you know how
every day we get an announcement of
another break-in another problem now
some of those with social engineering
and some of them are just weaknesses in
the system we know that things like the
DNS may name system mechanisms are very
sensitive to attack we know a lot of
things are sensitive to attack okay so
the there have been a number of attempts
to solve this problem by incrementalism
and I my own feeling is that we've run
out of steam we have critical resources
that are currently service by systems
which are just intolerably sensitive to
disruption now I banks power systems
water problems water systems are very
sensitive because they're running old
equipment they running on protocols that
are sensitive to a disruption and then
to top it all off the app the demands of
the of the system are getting higher as
we put more bits across the internet
near a whole set
about whether or not the current
packet-switching architecture and tcp/ip
is the right vehicle to go forward with
and I think it's time to actually set
back and say okay let's stop not stop
fixing things but now let's start
looking at what we should build going
forward in the future where we're going
to potentially have terabytes coming
across the network where we have
basically a substantial distributed
environment be cloud-based or whatever
that requires a level of security we
have not been able to achieve in the
current internet there are some examples
of what I would call and I'll go back to
some might work if I'm allowed to way
back when in 70s there was an nsf-funded
activity called just dcs distributed
computer system and there the idea was
the integrated network and the
processors in a network and set of
processes into a full tower and secure
environment it actually got built and it
did in fact do what we hope to would do
it actually was fault tolerant it was
reasonably secure and it was
distributable and out of became a number
of ideas which get rediscovered by the
field about every five years you know
the content addressing was there there's
just a number of things which is reason
i quoted having at the beginning that we
keep forgetting the past now if you ask
the average student some of these old
ideas that get replicated every five
years I capability systems they say oh
no no no nara and it's 22 Noble and
experiment most of them I don't think no
more texts from a hole in a wall
and yet these ideas will not redirect
Lee recent reproducible a buildable upon
now you need a vehicle to do that let me
go back to another experiment which was
successful in a very fundamental way and
in fact i think is good model for how i
would attack this problem about what ten
years ago now bobcat and i proposed why
proposed and vote Bob into it the
gigabit test beds the problem was that
we thought that the network was capable
of sustaining speeds even the TCP
network operating gig event but nobody
had ever tried it and in fact not only
nobody had ever tried it but we propose
the experiment we were told that why Bob
and nobody will ever need a gigabit and
I can show you two reviews that said
that yeah lament the thing that made it
very successful and it was successful
Vint Cerf said that it took three years
of the deployment time of gigabit
technology in this country which if you
calculate how much cost the government
with a rare bargain almost as great a
bargain as their investment in the
internet but we did was to form an
industrial academic cooperation we use
the industrial laboratories and their
capabilities to build things that no
university was capable building we want
to build real gigabit test beds not just
a laboratory model so it had to exist in
the real world so we needed the input
from communication companies to give us
bandwidth computer companies manufacture
and duplicate replicate the interfaces
to computers and academics and
industrial labs to thing
of the ideas and you know one model that
that I one event that I think was very
interesting one of my former students I
don't like the idea for my students it's
an interesting us thing most of the
world 1 i'd say one of my students but
davidson Kowski said he walked into his
laboratory and telcordia and he sold his
power people be getting recognized and
some he did and he couldn't tell which
were his employees in which was students
because they work together and three
independent activities yield the three
different attacks on gigabit test beds
and they were three of them running
around the country very successful but
not just an academic group going off and
thinking and not an industrial do plan
to produce products was to produce an
idea time to do that I think it's time
to create and it's a hard job I don't
think it's an easy job to sit down and
understand how we can take these ideas
in the past and new ideas and create an
environment which is inherently secure
I'm going to be very careful there
because usually when you deal especially
with processor architecture the comment
you'll have is you're going to create a
model but that might be not the model
you want in the future so don't do it
that's a jensen doesn't get you far
fairly fast and you have to take a leap
and you have to create an environment
which is at least in current technology
as secure as you can be and I think
based on past research and a number of
fields we know fundamentally how to do
that and I always felt that I think I
proved it once that if we had actually
had the garage environment in place I
could build an 10 secure environment
against all but black bag attacks which
a heart action pull off
he so what do I propose that we
undertake what I think the NSF likes
call grand challenge and create a test
bed environment when row Thea is to
think of the next generation of
environments in both the network the
processor and the software environment
and to produce protocols which I would
call security protocols because what I
like to do is it to be able to attach
non-secure environments to my network
and still protect the world against
there be a bear behavior as well as
processors processors which i can
guarantee as much as i know how to put
guarantee that they are not easily
penetrated we're not going to say
perfectly better term tradable so what I
do with it when I have it well I
proposed and I proposed this actually to
several groups in New York the other day
and nobody threw me out room so i assume
you might not or maybe you will i'm
happy i want to pick a model space to do
it do it for and the space that I want
to try is the financial industry they
have major major nightmares if you go
talk to the head of almost any of the
major banks the real heads they put
mildly disturbed it's a polite way of
putting it over the lack of security in
their environments and a potential
downfall that could come with it I would
like to create a prototype system which
not only gives you security but gives
you the capability of handling the very
high data rates that we're talking about
in the future I personally believe that
it's a different type of architecture
and then we currently use for the
network my own approach and I'm
perfectly happy to argue this and
probably will is a distributed memory
environment where basically they
operating as a distributor environment
with a network is just back playable
watch virtual environment with the
protection built-in and that they run
for the financial industry why do I pick
them there a problem and they have a
marvelous regulatory mechanism called
the Fed which can can under the right
conditions forced technology to be used
what am I going to do about the existing
internet prayer is appropriate that's
that's I should back we're going to have
to continue to patch okay but I think we
have to realize that we're patching and
we're not going to achieve a real
reliable environments curable
environment now let me let me try just
for muse Minh of amusement every time I
propose any secure environment a special
process environment you run into an
interesting problem which I'll go out
remember rights management okay I would
I i would argue that any real secure
machine which can I'd suede applications
from each other in a guaranteed way one
of those applications can be rights
management and so if you have such a
machine it provides a home for rights
management they could be and that was
one the arguments against machines like
the garage approach that would provide
the ability to rights management I think
we have to decide right off the bat just
how is important is rights management
how important the security and you know
to take to your deal rights manner
digital rights management stuff by law
and by copyright law or not by saying
that we can live in an environment which
is as fragile as we have yes sir what do
you think security me what does it mean
resistance be secure
and what rights are we talking about
copyright or access rights or I was
talking about copyright the Hollywood
rights management not the not the fact
of stuff that deals with who has access
to what internally that's a different
issue what I mean by securus I could run
with it in a protected environment an
application which can only reach the
things that it is access rights to and
that that's guaranteed there's no way of
going under it sideways etc and those
rights are maintained the cross network
again i have a funny idea what a network
looks like but across communication
capabilities so if in fact i have a
right to do it here i have the right to
do it they're if they're part of the
same and there's no way under it
protected against the examination by
third parties yes access to data would
be protected processes would be
protected there would be some mechanism
for ensuring that a process is initiated
only by an own party and so forth yeah
and stuff we note we've done in the past
in pieces and so no basically I proposed
to to a number of people that it's time
to actually go do that before i go on if
i go on do I get any reaction well I'm
happy to be thrown out but I would
actually have the historic part is what
were your impressions since I live the
competitors to the TCP and NCP era back
back then now a number of us who sit
next to me here we're hearing x.25 is a
clean or if you were working for big
blue or
good customer sna was good in here if
you get yeah well the actually the
competition in this country was widely
OSI European vs TCP there was a national
research council study of that which I
was on sub office Ron and the problem
fundamentally was that OSI was a commit
standards committee with all the
problems that come from standards
committee while tcp/ip was was basically
the IETF with a demonstrated capability
in the rough consensus so a lot more
flexible than the TCP approach to the
res there was some severe problems with
OSI as there were problems with TCP but
we felt that there was a lot more
flexibility in TCP than there was an OSI
that's 25 I mean we use that in CS no it
was perfectly reasonable but the NSA was
proprietary protocol wanted to stay quit
proprietary protocols and it was a
religious argument we did ask you to why
but I think on average I think the
decision to go with TCP was the correct
decision at that time and the ITF is
mechanism to establish quote standards
is not a bad technique with anybody else
yeah I thought I didn't write the other
protocols word anymore spirit is good
and then that yes sir if you're rolling
out a new protocol are how do you
prevent it from this supposed to do
everything everybody needs only prevent
it from exploding into the pile of
bloggers that became know as I and
gossip in particular missed the flavor
at that I
with care I'm serious I'm serious that a
lot of it can be both not into software
which floats around but into structures
that kept minimal again you if you
believe my assumption that we're going
to be moving around terrible piece of
information and there's remarkably
little time to do anything you know one
of the problems with TCP and I could get
thrown out for this one is that if
you're operating at carabus teach be
becomes a circuit switching network with
some bad behavior and so clearly is it's
time to we may call it TCP but it
probably won't be because of the
limitations package switching and I
think what have we done the hard way not
in software dedicated oh he make one
another bus yeah he had a enormous
impact on the whole yeah but they don't
come easily John was was unique person
because one of the things he had
enormous impact and he had no self and
graduate what sweater math
self-gratification he did it he did a
wonderful job just the cider shoe John
is known for his work in the ITF and
standards John's thesis was actually on
protocol verification and was pioneering
effort in that area though which most
people forget Paul Bako Petrus was Paul
yes sir and the past systems that we
built have security problems principally
because the economics involved we had
memory that we wanted to share so that
we could make more use of little space
and we designed multi-user systems so
that many people could use a single
machine is there some merit to to
rewinding there and in getting rid of
their virtual memory and all of that no
I never said that and machines like
multics did all the above in a what a
two level security eventually yes I
think we still need it yeah we may
choose to operate differently but I
think in general the multi-user machines
especially if they're accessing data
large data is necessary there's an org
landscape for that hardware and that
certain the semiconductors made changes
change how it build those machines not
really i think the structure machines
will change but not not the requirements
to have multi-threaded operation which
add memory the quote the thing i believe
is our shared memory will go
geographically shared as opposed to what
we do now which is sort of a funny form
of shared memory but it's not really
shared memory as far as the process of
concern now part of it is well I look at
the highest bandwidth interfaces and
most computers between the processor
memory if the other boy if I have and I
could be thrown out for this one is that
our communication between the processor
and everything else will be probably
optical it gets harder and harder to
support anything else or architectural
solutions for a changing economic
landscape I think the economic landscape
is fundamentally different today than it
was when
those systems were designed think it is
the things are gone cheaper now if you
look at a motorist machine now what's
capability of that I have probably more
power than my cell phone and I have our
multi machine I don't think that's the
issue i think i think the justification
for multi-threaded environments with
different applications is still there
shared memory is still there i would
argue that the shared memory will be
much more elaborate than it is now
because i need protection mechanisms are
a very high bandwidth you are hide
latency and all that stuff but i wonder
if we have a number of security
challenges and the security challenges
when I look at that I just I I think
their ways out of that to this value
even a mobile device has many needs for
compartmentalization functionality and
and its moment you have access to
everything yeah at one app does x.x
everything yeah that's yes I said what
if the story rights management you said
he wanted to start in rights management
and whenever somebody says that I always
wonder whose rights okay copyright law
that said 70 years yeah if you look at
my past I've been a member of the board
of trustees of eff for a long time and I
think that all rights are copyright laws
of Vulcan now they are very very bad
that's political process okay but is
there a technical solution put it will
be people who live in limited copyright
land to have no copyright protection on
things that are over 70 years old plow
in hollywoodland things are blotted out
forever hi how do you dress up problem
when it's just geography that affects
whether i can see a bit I think I think
you do by law and by technical
capabilities and say if I receive this
object it
it must conform to the copyright laws of
the country it's being played and viewed
in that's complicated because in fact
we're not doing things like that now
it's really time to rethink the whole
goddamn copyright especially to Mickey
Mouse yeah issue I've eff is fought for
years on that one what they add on top
of this is that the hardware itself is
something which can be tacked the
network the network structures the
mechanisms greater connectivity can be
hacked the software on a particular
system can be hacked at multiple levels
what do we need to do to protect the
very large number of levels that exists
in in a network history computing system
which is the Internet to make sure it
isn't easily hacked right now the
architecture of most machines we deal
with makes it almost trivial to hack
almost anything you can a CAD software
level the processor does provide the
proper framework to prevent that from
happening there's no way a really
compartmentalizing that isn't by
passable so it's it's almost sunless
trivial to hack and the Boise's is so
short I'm serious I think the Internet
of Things if it continues the way it is
now is going to be a major catastrophe
targets yes and if this goes if we
continue to way we're going to do things
we're asking for some major nightmares
yeah again and what I'm trying to do
here is to not get trapped in current
engineering issues and yes we need a lot
of people who do occur in engineering
and trying to fix these things
it's as a unstoppable wave to do the
internet of things because everybody
sees money in it and it's going to
produce a nightmare which will will have
to deal with for a while for a long
while but I would rather that not see
that perpetuate forever and so building
something that we can be reasonably sure
is bulletproof it's bulletproof as we
know how to make it and can operate at
the speeds that we're going to have to
deal with in the future and if you don't
think you like terabits at some point in
the game I think you're in the same boat
as people who said I you'll never need a
gigabit some some of the virtual reality
stuff we're going to demand extremely
high bandwidth extremely low latency
issue things none of which we can
particularly do right now and yes to its
additional problems with distributed
shared memory are like our PC is is
trying to abstract away the latency on
the error model do you have any thoughts
on how to do this I deal with well two
things I think I know how to deal with
the earth I know an attack on the error
model okay as far as the agencies
concerned you know one of the things we
do very very well in modern computers is
to deal with latency and you know every
computer we have from from the pc up and
back does of predictive caching get the
data where it's needed before it happens
we've been doing that for how many years
now with primary secondary tertiary
memories in caching I think we can get a
good handle on that being able to put
the make things appear where they should
be and minimize the future agency no
we're not it's not going to be perfect
because there is latency but we can do a
lot better than we do right now and
there are endless papers on this
at least 50 years yeah yeah actually it
at least 50 years I remember everybody
know George muy here yeah you would
George wrote the description of a IO
system back in what 50 60 to that dealt
with multiple levels who caching and
minimizing latency and maximizing
throughput etc again as I mentioned in
the abstract we we have a short memory
yes sir when the idea of user
disappeared you know we had users and
operating systems that logged in and had
credentials and rights to operating
system objects and then databases came
along and web apps came along and
suddenly the user became mediated by
this web app which translated that user
that users rights into a single database
user which had access to all the tables
to rewrite and even delete them perhaps
so you know how did we go so wrong in
that I you know I what I see maybe maybe
maybe I'm getting old is a reversion
back to the centralized computing
facility and we escaped that with the pc
and the large reasons that the pc was
successful in the industrial it's a
goddess way from the control of the
central computing facility the current
environment has put us back in the
control of that and users very well
prerogative i think in the in the world
where you have the isolation protection
of i'm proposing what I think should be
yeah the user becomes important again
because tomorrow yeah yeah yeah well
then yes so suppose you get this
well-designed architecture how do you
get it manufactured securely good
pumpkin
everyone proposed which I'm not sure
would work okay if in fact the financial
industry is patent enough okay they have
a lot of water power some the power
industry and well how industry itself
doesn't but the Fed the government's
have some capability financial industry
i think is an interesting target because
they buy a huge amount of stuff they
have major nightmares going forward
their security problems are beginning to
be non-trivial we don't know how bad but
as I think I said I talked to one of the
heads a very very very large
multinational Bank and he says the thing
he stays up at night worrying about his
security is there any theoretical basis
to believe you can make a processor that
self-aware being secure I think you can
build a process of which to the best of
our understanding can be made secure in
the sense of providing isolation and
protection right action it can the
processor itself be self-aware in the
sense of checking himself I think yeah I
think that's an interesting question and
I by the way I didn't say there isn't
some interesting research here okay I
meant this is not a trivial exercise in
producing this in fact we may not be
able to but unless we try we're not
going to be able to and I don't
personally don't like to look in the
future where we continue in and I'll go
and what we're doing now not yet I would
make the comment that if your your
mobile device and your laptop have
typically something on the order of two
dozen devices which are processors in
essence yes and a lot of those happen to
access to in memories yeah which they
said we have no idea most of them are
manufactured somewhere in another
country we throw them together there's a
composition problem here that nobody's
looking at right so your theoretical
approach and thus far has completely
ignored that problem I'm not all doing
that as I said there was some equipment
there are some very difficult research
problems which manufacturers large we
have ignored when is what they're
getting what they wanted to get I don't
know as any manufacturer actually dealt
with that for real fine manufactured
Commodore 64 emulator standoff it in a
nice little joystick yes and the people
she worked with the factories in China
we're always starting to redesign
everything because they always try to
redesign everything to shave a couple of
you know Millicent's off the price of
that which I'm not sure I like proposed
for that particular problem which we may
have to do some day now where I hope to
talk politics but I will know you read
the Japan who could say no ok Japan
could never say no I mean it didn't have
the economic base to say no China does
and we at some point in the game I'm not
an anti Chinese person but at some point
in the game we're going to have to
understand that what we put in our
credit office devices we may not control
and but again it's an interesting
question how do I know how do I know
that a chip for instance is doing what
it was designed to do that's something
the manufacturers have worried about
being able to reverse engineer their
mass so they can see if in fact what's
there is what they asked to be there
right I don't think I think it's more
complicated that's an interesting
research problem
yes sir all the problem of devices of
being able to us do things that they
shouldn't be able to do was even being
ignored back in the 80s when kikos under
witness security examination and they
said we don't worry about the i/o
controller say yes yeah I commented that
we actually dick having was considerably
more blunt in his comment and I laid out
the fact that we the academic my friends
are going to kill me for this well say
it anyway I think it's time to crack
down on both papers and theses and
require them to actually do the research
what has been done know if they if we
were physicists I'm assuming most
immersive engineers and we publish
papers such as published in computer
science often not completely I can't
curse the whole field where papers are
presented which which sounds like
they're describing a system which have
never been built the push of students to
publish five papers before they graduate
just generates some pretty bad science
the fact that we don't do research on pi
results and we replicate them in those
fields of science would be drummed out
on of a field business wouldn't dad do
that which ones I know it wouldn't
survive the online journal we do it and
we survive that's got to change again we
have to build on the shoulders
recognizing that they did things wrong
I'm not saying that you can just adapt
what's in the past but unless you have a
knowledge of that past you're going to
repeat the same errors most likely yes
and see us to 24 one of the things to do
is try to reproduce publish networking
experiments and see if the results hold
which is always interesting if it's
never considered publishable right
because it's it's not a new result
that's just reproducing an existing
results a verified well yeah I can tell
you a long story about things have
gotten better but the fact that number
of papers our theory is justified by
simulations okay now I this is historic
so I was brought up when I first arrived
at Bell Labs I worked for a guy named
military who had a very simple algorithm
you said never believe a simulation and
why should calibrated against a working
system because you have no idea in the
world what of how accurate it is yet
working system you can calibrate it if
you do calibrator you can make small
changes and still have some assurances
probably still valid but people go and
make remember the ethernet papers the
endless number of papers which ran
simulations on some minor change of the
ethernet and children one percent
improvement in a simulation that had to
have fifteen twenty percent variance
that statistical nonsense and yet they
were accepted and published and then
work based on that that's yeah we don't
teach statistics emotion computer
sciences we suggest there's a podcast at
came in yesterday with doug mon former
NSA former DARPA and now to Homeland
Security had a diet eight HR he made the
comment that we spend typically eighty
percent of our effort on the so-called
R&D and that's questionable yeah and
maybe twenty percent on tech transfer
what we really need is eighty percent on
tech transfer and remember he's in
applied research and flied development
but would you would you care to come in
on now
we think we need more time on tech
transfer now we do an a modest amount of
that in universities we transfer
technology to students who hopefully go
out and deploy it the thing that worries
me the most in our current R&D world is
if you look at almost every company that
says they spend X dollars for rd most of
it is for Dee and that is a real
catastrophe place up in edmond ok i
asked once you at that point i think
that was what spending 40 million our
R&D and the all was on the five million
know the IBM 40 million dollars in 1970
whatever it was where they finally
decided they needed religion on security
and the rumor was that was what is the
39 / 39 million on PR and 1 million
untraveled but actually I be I'm didn't
fairly nice design on that house oh we
had serious ones and once you've piled
the ok shared the crap out the annoying
structure was a very good vehicle for a
fairly high security environment but
they never they never showed it to the
world yes sir you've been in both the
telco world in the internet world the
telco world is big on billing and
metering uses a substantial portion of
bandwidth and code do that in the
internet world that's an anthem which is
right on the internet low but how do you
prevent the tragedy of the Commons where
you have no feeling no metering all you
have is advertised you get yourself oh
let me back up from him okay it depends
on what your metering I think it is not
irrational to put high water marks
quotas high-water mark so you can detect
things which overload your system but I
think you have to prove that overload
show system now adjacent Livengood
almost got drummed out of verizon of
comcast when he said that quotas were
not an engineering problem they were
marketing problem and I think that's the
issue that you have to separate if you
have somebody's consuming a significant
percentage of bandwidth and detriment of
others I think you have to do something
there's just no way this is what my
critical hat on okay there is no way you
you're going to meet a demand of
somebody who says I'm an application
which needs a gigabit to my home in
rural America it's not going to happen
without a major investment and west of
somebody's going to pay for that
investment it's not going to happen
period so there's this balance then
point if you're if you take the position
of we're going to build fabric like
their bit that goes across you're going
to kill kill the Golden Goose and
certainly the erode ibly unrestricted
bandwidth that we have now has has
generated a huge amount of business the
problem is it's taking away from one set
of companies giving it to the other
that's the FCC's mandate to take care of
that I you know I've spent a year at the
FCC other than a lot of papers on it the
FCC has become political and i think
that's it
what wasn't it wasn't portico when i was
there now chairman kanade basically said
that you know for instance i was invited
to the White House what's the security
thing he said you can't go so why can't
I go well because the FCC is an
independent agency and though we have
mechanisms if they want you they have to
go through this and we don't the current
chairman said yes sir I think it's a
basic problem than what what they do and
how they control and I'm really worried
about the fact that they are going to
kill the Golden Goose before we're done
yeah any remote what if anybody remote
there's no one there I can't see it so
somebody on what it can I just ask them
yeah turn the road but around so I can
talk to him 00 stand up yes hello hello
hello is this working is this eyelashes
can you hear me all right this is
shelled or the heckle bot yes um at the
beginning of your talk you mentioned
several places where computer science as
a science ran an experiment and you were
surprised by the results in in Sciences
like physics we may have a range of
values clinging back but we're seldom
surprised that something floats away on
its own nichter dainik has a theory that
any discipline that has to call itself
science like computer science or visit
our social sciences or political science
must not be a science because people in
physics don't need feel a compulsion to
identify themselves as it when will we
get to the point where this might
actually be a formal science and what
will we call ourselves then
I think yeah I'm phone actually by my
main kick there is economic science I
read the double papers with an economist
very good one and he says according to
economic theory and I asked him what our
passports in this theory you have I
don't get an answer so I walk away and
our engineering yeah well that's the big
problem you are our progress in software
engineering has been glacially slow it's
a very difficult problem especially in
the environment where now where they're
big sort of monsters and we really don't
understand how to kind of engineer I was
out talking with good old yes thank you
kick myself in the rear end CMU woman
Mary and sorry I spent a half day with
it and yeah we're making some minor
progress but it's relatively minor and
part of the problem I think is that
software and I could get into a real
interesting argument here the thing
closer to software is is an author
authoring a complex book and you know
it's not a science yet but putting it
together how to structure we we have to
get a handle of that and it's probably
not going to be a formal proof of
correctness over of something
the science isn't a science at all it's
an engineering practice it's not that
either it's not that either no but you
know is there any reason to believe the
computer science should be like other
sciences none then we casted a model I
think it ate its own environment but it
has to be it has to be has to have the
attitude of a science namely that when
you make statements they should be based
on evidence not hope this has been going
on since beginning when I when we did
dcs I kept reading these papers that
people written with distributed systems
that they were reporting on and you read
this long paper and at the end was
commented well sometimes we might think
of actually trying it that's and
throughout the whole paper there was
never a hint that this was just a an
idea okay that's not science can you
hear me can you hear me this is felt or
the heckled bot again ah early you
mentioned the 432 being a noble
experiment there are a lot of individual
technologies that derive from that the
existing floating-point standards the
caching mechanisms the way many of the
high-performance pinion ships worked the
transaction bus protocol a lot of the
micro coding techniques a lot of that
evolved from the various elements of the
432 project it was just as a whole that
it didn't quite work but it did it still
lives on to this day and many other from
well and it was an experiment and
experiment yield though things that are
extensible but as a as a commercial
product the comment was that that it was
not a successful commercial product for
whole host of reasons but yes the
technology that came out of it was very
extensible the same as I don't know of
anybody remembers IBM's experiment
building a telephone system
out of that came a whole host of very
very good ideas hello dr. dr. Farber
this is heckle bought again um one last
comment the enterprise with Siemens that
didn't work out quite right had the
acronym biin which was picked at random
but afterwards I said it stood for
billions invested in nothing well
destroy I here and I have no way of
authenticating this okay is that at
least no no way I'm going to claim is
that in fact they had an order for a
bunch of machines a bunch of the Gemini
machines not as a switching system but
for a certain agency in Washington the
company was on fifty percent by Siemens
fifty percent by Intel the customer
could not buy from non-us controlled
entity siemens they proposed that Celes
one percent we promise we'll never vote
it and seaman said that would not be
proper and so do you ought to banish
them within the product talk about this
sort of restart idea engineer financial
second be a practical lot of heart that
be yeah this may directly funded yes I
think will be funded by a combination of
industries by what they can supply the
NSF the government including DARPA
potentially funding and joint to do it
NSF itself is incapable in a funny way
of funding because they give grants and
grants of the annoying habit and you
know there's no way to hold of
investigate his feet to the fire that's
why in the gigabit test beds we we had a
joint funding thing so there was a way
of holding you know you said you were
going to do it do it damn it I don't
think we're talking about a lot of money
to begin with then initiates the design
issue
and it may be a very difficult very long
design with some experiments but you
know the payoff could be enormous if it
happens and the downfall of not doing it
could be enormously expensive so you
take a choice oh yes sir well that
brings up the commercial side of it i do
CPUs and so I can adjust that portion of
the overall security environment be or
the portions I cannot impress but as a
practical matter as a cpu designer on a
grant or even a small dedicated system
doesn't do anything what has to be into
the mass market and I am perfectly
capable of designing a secure CPU the
problem is I can't sell one if I could
convince a major part of the economy to
demand that could you sell them in the
mass market no we're not going to sell
the mass market and then there's no we
cannot because the economics of scale
but you drive your cost to do into it so
it becomes impossible and that point
you're a captured source for the
government research project but that's
not very useful yeah I hear what you're
saying there are have been companies
which have basically taken a reasonably
interesting attack on the security
aspect and created two products okay one
strip down basically for the mass market
well you just don't enable the good
stuff and the other way you do enable
the good stuff for the high cost
marketplace and I think that's the path
you take that was that's the fundamental
idea that I thought it was in back of
things like a grunge that you're not
going to be able to sell to you're not
gonna be able to sell that for added
value to the consumer but in fact you
can add the value to the specialized
market and we can make the whole thing
profitable but that you know that's an
interesting
well it was about to say is that if we
don't do it we may not have a market
capabilities to take merely one possible
approach and a micro architecture
without capabilities are not a downgrade
those are two different machines oh yeah
but if you're going to build one
depending on how you market it you can
still attack the base the mass market
what's the what's the cost difference if
somebody is paying for the design for
the secure environment and you're you're
basically crippling it in a funny way
for the mass market the Intel itanium
team and there was a bit in the
architecture that we wanted
architectural II expose the floating
point sticking it and because of the
cost of doing just that it's not exposed
and if you can sell to commercial
company customers because it will accept
the environment where now what you do
Intel with the SVX is facing that same
issue they think does marketplace I
think there is to shut down the remote
just a couple things we're about to lose
the remote 01 on short term social
problems best assault by contributing
PDF s mid-range to the long term from
we're all gonna be employed another big
big need for research here and
development but research with a big
capital R yeah question is how many
people put money into this long and run
and i think i think the financial model
you're using actually might work yeah
and sort of they have the power
practically they have the power in the
axis and the turns out there are a
couple of governors of presence of the
regional fed who know what's going on in
the world and they can exert one hell
water power
sit out there trying to siphon if we
don't do something about that with you
very much and
you